um good afternoon members
officers and those members of the public
who
are tuned in um just a few notes as
always this planning committee meeting
on the 5th of
august i would like to go through names
as always to see who's with us i am
aware
there are some uh substitutes because of
people not attending this afternoon
i don't call your name out don't worry i
will come to that in a moment so
as usual going through the names um
counselor auburn
please just say you're here if i don't
hear from you obviously i know you're
not
how's it going here councillor curry
here chair uh i know councillor
duckworth
isn't with us apologies counselor taylor
isn't with us
and council dennis isn't with us i'll
come to that in a moment
councillor braveherd here chair
council of ghana i'm here
thank you uh councillor scott
here chair uh councilman keane i believe
has given apologies
uh councillor pat moore
um she sends her apologies thank you
alan thank you for that
okay and obviously
i'm here so uh you'll be pleased to know
um
okay uh just a few uh notes
uh just to keep everybody and those who
haven't been with us which i'll come to
in a few minutes time
um if you have any technical differences
this afternoon
at meeting please get in touch with the
democratic service officer
who is charles this afternoon and his
telephone number
is 577-186
his number will be included at the top
of the chat
stream for your convenience
i will ask all participants when you are
not speaking please
mute your microphone uh this stops a lot
of background noise
and so we don't pick up on unusual
noises and so on
and that's throughout the proceedings
microphones must only be used
when the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain permission to speak please very
briefly indicating the chat box
that you wish to speak and i will come
to you as soon as that person's finished
uh with everyone present please ensure
the mobile phones are turned
to silent and they must not be used to
make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting
any other business and ensure that you
are in a quiet room
free from dis distractions uh for the
duration of the meeting
uh please note that this meeting is
being live streamed on the council's
youtube channel so obviously the members
of public can
uh tune in if they wish
members requesting to speak under
council procedure rule
20.1 the foreign members have requested
to speak
counsel they
and breedwood on agenda item
for c countless
raskin and rogers on item for
a and counselor farence on
item five if there's a any other
members apart from the committee wish to
speak could they please
state now
okay thank you uh the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking
with members please note the foreign
items
on their agenda agenda item for
a agenda item for
c agenda item one
apologies for absence we have apologies
been received from councillor dennis
duckworth keane and taylor
also a counsellor more i believe that
was just now
um in their place
we welcome councillor whitehead
as a substitute for the labor group
uh also councillor rosewski
uh do we have any other apologies or any
substitutes
no
okay thank you agenda item
two declarations of interest any members
have any
declarations please say it now
thank you helen uh councillor white had
a bigger pardon i just see your note on
here
i don't know where you are um
obviously a substitute approved and also
i'd like to welcome
nick hughes committee services manager
thank you for that nick um
agenda item 3a minutes of the planning
committee on the first of july
2020 do members agree that the minutes
of the planning meeting
held on the first july 2020 be approved
and
signed by myself which i hope you read
could i have a proposal please
propose a second it right would you like
to give your names
uh charlotte
david hart david thank you and second
goodbye george ruszewski
thank you george
and you all agree agreed
thank you uh gender item 3b
minutes of the planning committee on the
15th of july 2020.
the members agree that the minutes of
the planning committee held on the 15th
of july be approved and signed
by the chairman once again please
david hart thank you david uh secondary
yeah no arguing please
uh joel councillor recessor yes
yeah do you all agree agreed
thank you agenda item for the schedule
of planning applications and public
speaking
uh once again members i'm sure you're
aware of this the way things
are any site visits cannot take place
at present because of uh the situation
where finance in
so um we will have to sort that out
if there is an agreement about a site
visit very difficult as i'm sure you
understand
agenda item 4a which is the planning
application for
approval land north of cottingdan
road and east of lavender lane
ramsgate on this occasion
i would ask nick if he could read out
the printed statement he has received
please thank you nick
you chairman uh would you like to see
the sorry chairman is it the person
that's
uh right i believe you have
two yeah i do um
um mrs kisby this is kids yeah that's no
problem
thank you sorry about that thank you
that's right
[Music]
right uh can everybody hear me yes yeah
good so uh this
is uh the planning statement by uh mrs
kisby
so as a team we have worked closely with
emma fibbins of thanat district council
and kent county council
over the recent months to produce a
scheme of high quality
energy efficient homes using vernacular
styles and materials
set against the open landscape of the
fields beyond
the scheme works towards a positive
aesthetic impact on its surroundings
promoting
through strong articulation of details
via the use of porches
bay windows overhanging eaves and
changes in materials to create a
pleasant streetscape
and give the development a strong sense
of place while complementing the
surrounding area
further interest is achieved through the
use of a varied roof scape
of gables and hips and dwellings which
are designed to turn the corner
maximizing street frontages and
providing natural surveillance
the scheme has been laid out to avoid
interlocking between dwellings and to
neighbouring sites by providing all new
dwellings with generous gardens
rear gardens do not back onto public
spaces and side gardens have been
avoided
the dwellings have been set back from
the road edge and off street parking has
been incorporated for all dwellings
adhering to kent county council highways
recommendations
given the previous agricultural nature
of the site landscaping and ecology are
at the forefront of our approach to the
site layout despite it being species
poor at present
breaking up from the built form with
native planting and spaces between the
homes allows us to avoid an
urban environment with the overall aim
of enhancing the local area
and built environment we have also
provided
areas of open space to the centre and
north of the site
and created planting buffers between the
development and cottington road
boundaries have been reinforced with
native tree and hedge planting to
provide both screening to the site
and the neighboring properties helping
to create wildlife corridors
the provision of bird and bat boxes log
piles and holes in fences for hedgehogs
have been provided across the site to
the approval of the kent county council
ecology team
to close with the planning officer
recommendation of approval
we hope that you will support our
application to provide much-needed
high-quality housing in thanet
with the construction works to be
undertaken by local contractor w w
martin limited
uh thank you nick um again i'm going to
ask nick to read
a statement help raising points of
concern
from a mr willoughby brown
thank you nick thank you chairman
uh statement mr willoughby brown i along
with many others vigorously object to
the proposals being put forward by orbit
homes for social or any other form of
housing
cliff's end is an area where most people
are homeowners who purchase their homes
to live in a semi-rural location
a village they purchased an environment
not just a house
not an urban sprawl cliff's end is an
already overcrowded village there is no
infrastructure in place to accommodate
any more houses
many families have more than one vehicle
the traffic and parking in the village
is already under stress and is becoming
increasingly worse
the bus service has stopped and if it
did resume it would impact the problems
with the country lanes
an extra 60 plus houses total orbit
development
could increase the traffic in the
village by at least 70 to 80 vehicles
if not more cottington road and fodes
lane are narrow country lanes with no
pavements no yellow lines or parking
restrictions
and are not suitable for existing
through traffic additional traffic will
make the area even more dangerous
there is one play area and one village
hall residents including children and
the elderly need to cross boats lane or
walk on
unpaved roads to access these many
outside visitors to the play area
park their cars on foa's lane resulting
in single lane traffic
obstructing the view of the road and
therefore making crossing the road
treacherous
an accident waiting to happen in recent
communications the government recognises
that pubs libraries village shops etc
are essential to communities and form
part of the fabric of areas
there are no such provisions for the
community in these proposals in fact
the poorly researched application or
sales pitch says that the village has
various amenities
such as a pub that currently lies empty
with the owners wanting to turn it into
more unwanted housing
people and cars and of course more money
for the developers
and a village shop which is closed as
the effect of increasing population been
thought of
we already have overstretched schools
hospitals and doctor surgeries
more houses will only exacerbate the
increasing anti-social behavior
traffic congestion and noise and
decrease the quality of life for
existing residents and future ones
there is also a religious and historical
connection to the proposed site
it's the place where saint augustine
introduced christianity to the country
therefore this site should be protected
and treasured
it is not where 100 social housing
development should be built
completely out of character with the
environment government
reformation of the planning system
proposes
to reduce pressure to build on
greenfield sites and deliver more homes
that fit the character of the local area
delivering more high-quality
well-designed homes and beautiful and
greener communities for people to live
in
this application hasn't really been
thought through planning is there to
create a better
environment for people not to assist
developers with their bank violence or
transient politicians with their egos
the tragedy is that the mistakes created
whilst in office last a lifetime
as we are no longer a member of the eu
we actually need our farmland more and
we need more than just houses
a view shared by our local mp sir roger
gale
i have so far opposed every airplane
application for the building of houses
in cottington road cliffs end it seems
every time that i or anybody else
subjects to an application developers
and their lawyers amend the application
making it necessary to go through the
planning process all over again
maybe a deliberate attempt to thought
the many reasonable and intelligent
objections to their unwanted proposals
raising justified concern about the
planning and objection process
end thank you very much nick
um speaking as well counsellor
councillor ratagan please
you have three minutes
um i'm speaking on behalf of uh two
residents um in
in in the wards um the main concern is
the outline planning was based on
30 social housing the residents were
told this wasn't going to be rented
but you know uh where um uh people can
buy
and share you know the cost of the
scheme this has now increased to seventy
percent of the
development share ownership and thirty
percent as rental uh properties
uh so a lot of residents feel that the
original allotment of the third
and final house and should be made and
maintained because that was the basis
of the original planning commission um
it's a major demand for the village well
you know where there's gonna be a huge
huge increase in families uh by the
increased housing
uh like the the last gentleman who
knicks
res out there is no amenities there um
there's no shops
there's no pub and they closed many
years prior to the application being
made
and also uh residents are having to pay
for their own screening because the site
does and i've been down and visited this
site down there
the uh the site really overlooks the the
properties uh behind behind there
uh and one resident has had spend just
over two thousand pounds and
uh putting high fence in just so he can
regain his uh privacy
um so you know our our
sort of aim is really that the uh
outline planning was uh given on on 30
social housing so that should be um
should be stuck to you
thank you council raticon uh also
speaking um
his board counsellor uh which i
understand you have a couple of comments
from residents um
councillor rogers thank you thank you
karen thank you members
uh besides voicing the views of the
residents i've been asked to speak on
behalf of mrs helen knowles and mr peter
parsons
at this point i'm voicing the objections
of mrs helen knowles the cleveland
president she has noted that further
reserve by's plans have been submitted
on the 23rd and 27th of july she wasn't
notified and was unable to object to
them
she notes that two street lights are to
be placed directly behind
11 oakland court she strongly objects to
these that she has a sensitivity to
light while sleeping
there were no street lights visible from
the main bedroom of her house when she
bought it 17 years ago
and these lights are positioned almost
opposite each other she suggests that
only one line is necessary
her objection as previously stated in
her email of 20th of february
is that the house to be built directly
be behind 11 oakland court which is now
plot 22
previously plot 21 appears to have
windows overlooking her kitchen
conservatory and garden
she would like to remind you that one of
the planning committee members
present on the original application
agreed with her that this was
unsatisfactory and stated that a single
story dwelling
should be built behind eleven oakland
hall
as this has not been taken into account
she respectfully
respectfully suggests that plot 22 be
turned round so the side of the house
that does not have windows he's
overlooking 11
oakland court
um i'm now speaking for mr and mrs
parsons
of beach grove they state that the
original outline planning agreement of
30
affordable housing should be upheld and
not changed to 100
to ensure that the site is fully in
keeping with the surrounding properties
the upper windows and back gardens of
the new development would impact hugely
on the residents of beech grove
resulting in loss of privacy and
overlooking he also asked
that the plans for mitigating the impact
on beech grove oakland court and
lavender lane
should be strengthened and not simply be
reliant on limited fencing
trees and shrubbery within the ownership
of existing residents
the current fence was evolved as a
perimeter to an agricultural field
not for secure buffering between
back-to-back houses
uh going on to my views the developers
planning statement states that cliffs
end has
a preschool closed 2018 post office in
short
that closed in 2016 public health
that closed in 2017 and a bus service
that ceased a while ago
so it seems that the homework wasn't
done on this perhaps
orbit would like to fund these
facilities as they say the societies
were located to benefit from the use of
these local services
and facilities the change from 30
to 100 affordable housing on both sides
of cottington road
is a significant increase and
dramatically changes the dynamics of the
development and village
this application now consists of a
higher density of terrorist
multiple multi-occupancy and
semi-detached houses
the new layout is unacceptable to the
residents of cliffs end
and i would ask you that you refuse this
thank you
thank you council rogers just to mention
which i forgot to mention to members um
officers with us this afternoon uh the
planning applications manager
uh mr ian livingston um
planning officer emma fibbins and our
committee clerk
which is uh charlotte crowley
uh so can i move on i believe it is emma
uh
i'll be corrected um for your report
please
yeah thank you chairman i'm just sharing
my screen
okay so the proposal is um
for the within the area outlining red on
this plan
um cottonton road um you can see in this
location here
um to the left is lavender lane and
the right is beech grove so the
properties back onto that
that site here and the area in blue is
not part of of this application but is
part of another application that
members will see on another agenda and
so this is an aerial view
of the site so the um site is located
here
and then a closer view of that so in
this area here so the rear boundary of
the site runs along
this area in line with the rear of the
properties
um to front in lavender lane
and then these are just some um 3d um
google views
towards the neighbor properties so this
is lavender lane running on the western
boundary of the site
and you can see the location of the
existing properties so they're quite a
distance
from the western boundary um and you can
see this property
on the right hand side here the fact
that there's um
limited tree screening along here but
there's quite a lot of tree screening to
the left
and along this area here and then this
is looking now towards the properties
um the front onto beach grove so this is
the eastern boundary of
of the site so again you can see an
existing tree screen that
exists along part of that boundary
this is now a photo looking into the
application site and so this is it as it
currently stands
this is looking towards the northern
boundary of the site
uh again looking towards the northern
boundary of the site and now seeing part
of
the eastern boundary and properties in
beech grove
and then coming along again the
properties in beech grove now this is
the
again the eastern boundary of the site
and now you can see again in relation to
the road um
so this is the reserve masters
application the outline application has
has already approved the principal
development and the access
including some off-site highway works so
um
those works included some footpath
provision along the side of the road
here
and now this is looking to the western
boundary so this is lavender lane
and you can see here and the existing
properties behind and again you can see
the tree screen and on the left hand
side here you can see
the grade 2 listed central gusting's
cross
and this is now taken in front of the
site with the application site on the
left so you can see
this is cottons and road running through
the middle
and then this is looking again along
cottage and rain laying towards
um lavender lane and again you can see
the the monument in the distance
and this is now taken from outside the
monuments the monument is off to the
right hand side here
um sort of across and this is looking
towards the application site so
these are the properties front in
lavender lane with the application
site behind these properties
so as i said this is a reserve matters
application
for so the matters that um members need
to consider are the layouts of the
development
the appearance scale of the development
and the landscaping
um so the so the proposal was 41 units
um this is the number that was approved
through the outline so the principle
this number on the site has
has been agreed and this includes the
impact on any um
uh any highway movements resulting from
this development
so the proposal is for a mix of uh
semi detached and terraced units there's
also two flats
within the site as well um you can see
that there's a mix between the
detached at the entrance of the site
there's a few terraced
um towards the center um in terms of
looking at the pattern of surrounding
development the majority of surrounding
properties are
semi-detached or detached but there are
some examples of terraces
um within the village within the
application site
the the terrace properties are only in
groups of three so they're not
significantly
um large terraced blocks um there is a
group of four on on the
western side but again these were quite
centrally located within the sites the
majority of units you would see would be
the larger
spatial units from the entrance you can
see as you come into the site from the
central access point there's an area of
open space towards the center which
would be
a communal um informal open space area
and again there's a open space area
towards the north of the site adjacent
to the northern
boundary um in terms of landscaping the
proposal is
for the road to be in tarmac but you can
see the pink areas of all the um
paving areas to be provided so all
carpool areas will be
would be paved and there's new tree
planting proposed within the open
um space towards the center here and
also adjacent to
the southern boundary so through the
outline consent consideration was given
on
the impact on the setting of the grade
greater listed central augustine's cross
as you saw there's quite a distance from
the um application site to the cross so
it's not considered there will be any
significant impact
but it was suggested that there should
be some landscaping buffer provided
towards the
entrance to the site in order to reduce
any impact so this you can see to the
front of the site here
um a minimum five meter and landscaping
buffer
which would reduce reduce the impact on
that on that on the
listed cross
so just moving on to show you some of
the designs these are some of the
examples of the designs of the
properties within
the site so the traditional design
properties they're all with pitch roofs
um red bricks some weather balled in and
render is is proposed and
windows would be set within a reveal and
the roof would be
um clay clay tiles so there's again
different examples of those building
types
there's um at least five different
building types within the site and
within each of those different building
types there's again
variations where there's a mixture of
materials used
you can just see um
different varieties like this one's
showing the cladding so originally it
was proposed
said to be white cladding but this has
now been changed to black because it's
big cities that's more in keeping
with the village location and again
there's some bay windows
um features that are characteristic of
the surrounding area
so this is a street elevation showing
you um within the site itself
so this section is is um section zero so
if you look on the left hand side of the
layout plan
this is the the stretch of buildings
running along the western side of the
site
so you can see um there's a mix with
some um gable features
there's some bay windows within the
development um they're all two-story
buildings so again in terms of scale
they're in keeping with the um general
scale surrounding
surrounding buildings and moving on this
is
section one so this is now looking along
the
um eastern side of the site this group
of buildings here
so again you can see the mix of
materials with some black
weatherboarding
and render and the use of the red brick
and then looking at section two which is
looking towards um the open space the
open space is this area
in front of the property here buildings
running along
this row here again you can see there's
generous spacings between the buildings
and it is in in keeping with them the
general pattern of surrounding
development
and this is now um looking at section
three so this is along
um the north of the site looking towards
this row of properties here
and again you can see quite large um
spacings between the building
and you can see the mix in different
roof colors and again the mixing
materials across the
across the side and this is now looking
um section
four so this is looking towards these
few houses on the right hand side of the
left access road here
and then this is section five looking
towards
the properties in this area here
and then here are some visual um visual
perspectives showing
um how the proposal could look within
the site so i'll just click
through a few of these so again you can
see um the builders are set back from
the road they've got spacious frontages
and space for parking
in terms of parking there's two spaces
per property
and one space for the um flats and then
there's an additional 15 vista parking
spaces
now in terms of looking at the impact on
neighbours which was one of the um
main considerations um we've looked at
the distances between the rear
elevations and the neighboring
properties on on both sides
amended plans have been submitted
through the application which have
pushed these properties further from the
neighboring residents originally there
was a minimum distance of approximately
21 meters but we've
asked for that to be increased and given
the fact that there's currently no
overlooking from this site to the
neighbor so we feel that a greater
distance is required
so the properties mainly affected would
um
be this property here number 519 beach
grove
there's a distance of 25 meters from the
corner
of this property and the rear renovation
of the proposed units
um with a distance of approximately 30
meters to the the central garden area
um and for this property on the um i'm
indicating here there's a distance
of um 23 meters between the rear
elevation list property
and the um proposed dwellings
so they do um exceed
the what we would normally consider to
be a minimum distance
guideline when when considering the
issue of overlooking
in addition to that there is the tree
screen that runs along the boundary
although it is appreciated that
um at certain times of the year there
would be more overlooking
than the others um there's also some
boundary treatment along this boundary
and we have
recommended a condition that has
suggested a two meter high fence is
erected along this boundary where
there are gaps within that boundary
treatment
um and uh in terms of the rear
elevations it is accepted that there are
bedroom windows within these but given
that distance and
the boundary treatment um that we're
proposing along with the tree screening
is considered on balance the impact on
the neighboring residents would be
acceptable
for the presidents um along here with
beech grove there's a minimum distance
of 30 meters so again quite a good
distance between
the properties and again all of these
are not two stories there's no um rooms
within the roof at all
on the left-hand side um the main
properties affected would be
these ones um and the top of the
property in the top corner
which is the closest all the others are
quite a distance away
so the the distance here is um
32 meters between the rear elevation and
the side elevation of this property and
there's a distance of 20 meters from
the proposed rear elevation and this um
the boundary here so whilst there's a
there's a garden area within this space
it's considered the distance is adequate
enough to
prevent any significant overlooking
there's also within this area here
um a buffer area which has the potential
for some
tree screening so there's tree screening
along this part of the boundary
and it seemed that there's some space
for some landscaping in this area here
which doesn't fall within the
application
site so so
i'll just show you quickly following on
from that the photo so just to remind
you this is
then on the right hand side looking
towards the beach grove residence so
this as you can see during
the winter there is more overlooking
because the the trees
um are older it's in leaf um
then just again showing you the
properties here
with the tree screening during the
summer
and then these are the properties that
would back on to that one so you can see
this is the rear elevation with the wind
up central window
and then these are the other properties
with the other two windows
and then with the lavender lane side
again just remind you of the photo
towards those properties
and then this is the the property that i
was mentioning with the distance of 32
meters to that elevation
and 20 meters to this boundary here
where you can see there's some hedge
screening
so the impact on on these properties are
considered to be acceptable
and that's just showing the properties
that would back onto it and the rear
window so in terms of other issues i
think
affordable housing has been raised as
one of the biggest issues and the site
is being proposed
as 100 affordable housing um this plan
shows the location of the rented unit so
the pink units are the rented units
within
the site all of the purple units
are shared ownership units now
there was a requirement for 30 of the
development to be affordable
and through the outline consent there's
no policy that's
that it can't exceed 30 so we don't have
a policy justification to refuse a
development just because
it's come forward for more affordable
housing than what we've
originally approved um in addition to
that there is a
a big need for affordable units within
the district
um as mentioned within my report the the
council's recently had their housing
strategy adopted which
is showing um at least 309 households in
in serious need of housing and there's
2354 households on the register so
there is a strong need for affordable
units we're in the district and
therefore we would
not be um discouraging developers from
providing affordable housing as long as
it doesn't impact
on the community mix given the size of
the site and it's quite a small
um small size of site the fact that
only a limited number of rented units
are proposed so
whilst it's 30 of the site is only five
more rented units than we would have
approved through the outline
so with the majority of the site being
shared ownership is not considered there
would be
any real um detrimental issues to the
community with the majority
being being in that use
so given the fact we have no reason to
justify refusing
a scheme because of the 100 provision um
this is this is not being raised as a
concern so
um overall is recommended for approval
on the basis of the development is
considered to be in keeping with the
surrounding character appearance of the
area
that there's not to be any significant
um impact on
neighbouring immunity the highway issues
have been resolved in terms of um
parking provision and layout and
highways have no concerns with that
and parking provision is considered to
be adequate and in terms of landscaping
there's
there's exceeds the minimum requirement
for open space within the site
and the tree screening along the front
and boundaries
is considered to um adequately serve the
development so it's recommended for
approval
thank you thank you very much emma
i move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted
um could i have the vice chair second
please
sorry uh yes i was saying that
thank you councillor carmen cook uh
right members
wishing to debate this i have first of
all councillor auburn
yeah thank you chair um well let's start
really um i think there's a
the the messages coming from some of the
residents um i found to be a bit snobby
but there you are
that's just my feeling um the site in
itself
is more than adequate to uh
take this development the layout and
the uh design of the houses uh
more than adequate the 70
of uh shared owned ownership is also
adequate uh there's there's a few
social housing which we should all
support because not everybody can afford
to buy up to buy a house
um the issue of the uh of
saint augustine's cross i think as a
christian chairman
um i'm sure saint augustine would have
been very pleased
that a development was was taking place
that would that would accommodate
uh that would accommodate people who
can't afford to buy their own house
and also would uh would happily support
the development of shared ownership so
people can get on that
housing ladder
and i think overall chairman the
development
the development is uh is very good
and is more than welcome and our fully
supported chair thank you
thank you councillor alban i think
obviously you're old enough to remember
saint augustine perhaps you could get in
touch
for his approval um councillor whitehead
are you there yes just sorting my
microphone
thank you um
i don't think it's a particular secret
that we are constantly struggling
to provide affordable and accessible
housing
for our residents and so i find it very
encouraging that we have
a hundred percent development at this
point and that this step has been taken
i think it's significant um
to look at the percentages involved
we have 22 percent rented and
78 um
shared ownership so i think we have an
interesting
and useful mix of demographics there and
we also have a wide mix of property
types
um we're not looking at a development
simply of one-bedroom flats we're
looking at family homes we are looking
at three beds
um we're looking at a development that
covers
pretty much all of our potential
population demographics
in terms of the facilities
i think it's also important to remember
that we have
strong evidence across the country that
the building of housing does promote
and does accentuate the building of
communities
the availability of shops the
availability of facilities
the fact that certain things don't exist
at this point does not mean that they
will not exist in the future and quite
often development
specifically infrastructure development
does um
provide this i'm
aware and appreciative of the efforts
that have been made
both in terms of screening and moving
the boundaries outwards
um i think it's heartening that casey
the highways
don't have an issue at this point
um and yes i would like to again
make it very clear just how important
affordable housing is
for all of our residents and for our
entire community
thank you uh thank you for that uh
councillor whitehead um councillor joel
bayford
thank you chair i think the thing to
consider here
is that the principle of development
has already been agreed i understand
that
exactly how some of the residents must
feel about the change to their
environment but it's going to come
anyway
as far as i can see this development is
tastefully planned there is a variety
of housing style um
i think the fact that 82 is shared
ownership is also
a positive consideration
unfortunately in view of not
unfortunately perhaps but i think
in view of the fact that 82 is
shared ownership and that the fact that
principal development is already there
i really can't see any reason to refuse
this application
and i think the objectives maybe should
be careful what they wish for because
uh any any other development may not
be as sensitive as perhaps this one is
thank you chair
thank you councilman ford uh councillor
zesky
thank you chair yes looking at the uh
development uh
the fact that it's uh quite tastefully
done um
we do need more affordable
housing in than it
it's the area that this development is
going to be located i think uh
it will eventually get its extra shots
of matt when
uh people do move into the area so i
will support this
um and go for approval thank you chair
thank you councillor heart
thank you chair um i'm only just trying
to uh a couple of things i
think it's a good idea i'm not against
it per se um but councillor rogers
um mentioned something about a bungalow
being opposite
for uh plot 22 but that
doesn't seem to have happened so what's
going to happen with that if the officer
couldn't uh tell me about that
and why is it assumed that somebody in a
flat only needs one
car um do they assume that everybody
who's going to live in a flat
is a single person um you know why is
there only one space for a flat i just
can't get my head quite around that
if the officer can answer that as well
please thank you
emma can you come back home possibly one
of those
yeah sure um so the flats are only one
bed flats
um so it's not the case that we would
only ask for a one parking space
because it's a flat it's just because
it's one bed flat so therefore it's just
expected that only one vehicle is likely
to be needed for a one-bed unit
um and in terms of the bungalow i do i
do um
i do think that i heard that um the
address being referred to was oakland
call which is actually not
in relation to this application it's in
relation to
um this the other application which is
south of cottageton road which is not on
this agenda so
i think that was uh um
the redress being referred to so this
one is only affected by
residents in beech grove and lavender
lane and not open court
thank you emma i can't see
any other members wishing to speak so
thank you for that
so i'm going to put it to yourselves
that
um the motion is for approval
uh once again i will call your names out
uh
if you're for it please for or against
or abstain uh counselor coleman cook
for councillor auburn for
councillor bayford for councillor curry
for councillor ghana
four councillor heart
for councillor zesky for
cancer scott
four council right
four councillor whitehead
four and myself i'm
four and i think charlotte that is
carried
i don't hear anything so thank you
charlotte on my screen easy say
thank you members um and i did note uh
earlier on uh with councillor scott that
say he may have to leave
uh because of his work so thank you uh
matthew for that um okay the
motion is carried on that one so moving
on to agenda item c
which is a planning application for
approval
of the plate some peter's pedestrian at
117 canterbury road
westgate on sea um
once again we have um some statements to
be read out and if i could ask uh mr
hughes please
uh i believe you have one from
mr hume to start with indeed
yeah let me just make a net
thank you chairman this is the statement
of mr hume
good afternoon members this application
site comprises the vacant and redundant
sin peter's church which
closed in july 2014 the size
configuration and construction of the
church and everyday operation of the
building was costly and inefficient for
the limited numbers
which last used the building upon
disposal the diocese explored a number
of alternative options for its use
all of which were unsuccessful this
resulted in the sale of the building
after a period of marketing the church
has been vacant in excess of six years
with parishioners now served by nearby
facilities in westgate and fletcher
the loss of the church has previously ex
sorry
the loss of the church has been
previously accepted when granting
permission
in 2018 for it used by the offices
the consent is implementable until june
2021
and represents a full back position for
the applicant
the proposal includes the mixed
provision of 14 dwellings
as well as 751 square meters of office
space
close to the heart of westgate which
will provide economic benefits to the
local community with creation of up to
65 new jobs
the church itself was constructed in
1964
and is neither listed nor locally listed
officers have agreed the churches have
reduced community and aesthetic value
the design of the replacement building
has followed extensive engagement with
lpa officers and is considered to
represent an enhancement to the
conservation area it is acknowledged
that the proposed building is larger
than the existing church
but the building will stand within a
very large plot and the main four-story
element will be focused in the centre of
the site
and well separated from its boundaries
whilst the site occupies a roadside
frontage the proposed building is set
back from the highway edge
and will be screened by a dense belt of
protected trees which will be retained
and enhanced
it is considered that the siting of the
proposal and intervening trees combined
with quality as a proposed build form
will have a positive impact on the
character of the area compared with the
current buildings
the application has been supported by a
number of technical reports and the
proposals are considered to be
acceptable in terms of ecology
archaeology flooding drainage and
transport
the proposals will also deliver a high
quality of residential amenity for
existing prospective residential
occupants
to summarize the proposal seeks to
optimize the potential of this
sustainably located
brownfield site and will deliver a
quality mixed-use scheme of local
housing and employment floor space
members are respectfully requested to
support the application in line with the
office's recommendation
and thank you very much nick
i also understand you have a statement
of raising points of concern from ms
gray
well they're just chairman i'm just
don't worry
you okay yeah i'm just waiting for my
computer to load
okay one of your people nick
person who shows us all how to work
these things
i know i shouldn't blame the computer no
sorry it's been very slow
[Music]
[Music]
i won't embarrass members or the public
by going into a song
yeah thank you for that chair thank you
i thought you'd gone to her phone
you know who
do you need a handle nick
no apologies chairman bear with us for a
second hold on let me just see if i can
find another way of finding it
hold on i think we need to contact
democratic services chair well i was
thinking the same i know
you know i believe one quality um
you can't get the staff no exactly it's
gonna hold it all falls apart
i know
[Music]
right okay what's the holiday
exactly exactly
right and i always say i do hope all
your families and yourselves are
keeping okay in the situations we're in
well we're still here chair
yeah that's good good yeah i think we're
very lucky to be living
where we do we all do i can't imagine
being
you know in in a an urban area in a flat
where you can't get out and about we're
very lucky we have lovely walks things
like that
exactly yeah exactly
steve do you know when they're closing
off broadstairs high street
um no not not directly george um
i'm not sure that decision has actually
been been made yet i know we're looking
at it but i'm not
sure when it actually is george okay a
lot of people are asking so
yeah for sure yeah
can i these members and i hope
members uh please if we can keep to the
subject remember
public are possibly watching us
and uh i think i make sense um
i do understand that things are
happening with very high streets and so
forth but
i think that's for another time if you
don't mind me saying that
save any embarrassment to anyone thank
you
nick okay apologies uh committee about
don't worry
please don't worry uh the um
comments of westgate on sea town council
gate on the town council is not opposed
to change it understands the need for
development
however we feel this application within
a conservation area requires comprehend
compromise to save healthy mature trees
from unnecessary destruction
the town council welcomes the relocation
of miles
and bars main offices to westgate on sea
and is grateful for the possible
increased employment in the town
however the great number of flats
proposed on top of the ground floor
offices
by kentish projects has resulted in an
extremely large development
and large concreted area for associated
car parking spaces
it should be noted that this site is not
allocated for housing in the local plan
despite this the size of this
development means that nine trees
are being proposed for removal many of
which are due to car parking
cutting down trees unnecessarily for car
parking is a disgraceful act
even if new trees are planted mature
trees hold large quantities of carbon
and the planting of new trees does not
match the carbon lost for decades
then district council has agreed to
reach net carbon zero by 2030
and so preserving the current tree stock
is imperative to save stalled carbon
westgate town council welcomes
developments which do not cut down trees
unless absolutely necessary
and in this case we feel that it is
completely unnecessary
also the canterbury minster road
crossroads is a very busy area for
traffic
which may become busier with the 2000
houses allocated on the westgate fields
allocated through the local plan it is
imperative that we preserve our mature
trees in this area
helping to cleanse the air of traffic
pollution
these trees also mitigate against
surface water flooding and give homes to
birds and insects
they give beauty to the area of westgate
especially along minster road where they
can be clearly seen or greatly valued
planting new trees will not afford the
same value as those mature trees
currently in position
the tdc tree officer has written a full
report and we hope that this
has been available to you we are
concerned that only advice from the tree
specialist employed by the developer was
on the tdc portal and not from your own
tdc officer
your officer has given his sound
professional judge
professional advice and is paid by tdc
to do this and has provided a solution
rather than just a roadblock to the
development
he explains that two trees could
reasonably be relocated for the
development to take place
and the town council agrees with this
after careful consideration he concludes
that the large mature home oak trees
which the developer wants to remove for
car parking should not be removed
but should still be protected he then
explains in detail how this can be
achieved whilst at the same time
allowing car parking and allowing the
development to move forwards
we agree that the large mature home oak
trees proposed to be cut down within
this conservation area
should be protected and that this
development should only be approved with
conditions attached
the tdc tree office's clear plan should
be seriously considered as a reasonable
outcome and compromise
which saves these grand trees and allows
development at the same time
end quality
no don't worry nick these things happen
thank you very much um
uh speaking as well counsellor
councillor breedwood
hi can everyone hear me okay i can we
can i think yeah
thank you thank you chair the
application looks to make productive use
of a currently unoccupied area of land
the application also has intent to make
a meaningful contribution towards the
supply and delivery of much
needed local housing and office space
i'm talking positive about this
application
because i'm very supported supportive of
development however this particular
application
does not respect the conservation area
and the building within it
where escape towns will have objected
west gate on sea conservation area
advisory group have ejected
milegate civic society have objected as
well as many residents
in my opinion this proposal is purely
led
by a commercial desire to maximise the
profit potential
a four-storey flat roof structure shows
a remarkable lack of empathy for the mid
immediate surroundings as well as having
a huge impact for the neighbouring
property
the current building has architectural
importance similar to westgate library
which is just across the road in my
opinion this building
would be best served as a community area
or another non-profit use
westgate already has an allocation of 2
000 houses in the local plan
so we simply don't need to remove a
piece of architectural importance to
make way for more homes
i would urge this committee to go
against the officer's recommendation
and completely reject this proposal
until a more aesthetically pleasing
application is submitted
thank you chair thank you councillor
braywood
uh also speaking as a world councillor
councillor bainbridge
thank you chair just on meeting my mic
um
[Applause]
yes councillor bainbridge westgate on
seaward
um i spoke on this last time it came to
the committee in support of the
application
as i could see the benefits to westgate
of renovating this site
and i appreciate the plans of changing
the building
i appreciate the plans have changed and
that the building is now going to be
replaced and constructed as offices
on the ground floor and apartments on
the upper three levels
um i've looked at the plans and i think
the building is of an attractive design
i don't think i'm looking at the same
um plans that um you know like maybe um
councillor braidwood was looking at
because i thought this building looks
nice
um and i feel like it is in keeping with
the street scene
i know that it's actually at a lower
height than the building next door and
the impact on neighbouring properties
does not appear to be any different than
that of the existing property in terms
of light
with no physical overshadowing and
traffic and highways agree in principle
i know they've stipulated
some conditions that i think will be
able to be met by
um by the developers and the protected
trees are being maintained
and new trees are being planted the
pluses for westgate are that this
development will bring 65 plus jobs to
the area
where marston bar will set up their head
office this will have a positive impact
on the shops and cafes that would gain
trade
um trade in the area westgate doesn't
have many large employers so this one
would be very welcome
um we also need high quality housing and
this development also provides welcome
additional homes in westgate
the last thing i want to see is another
derelict building sitting there
going to rocked for years and years to
come this building has already been left
deserted for six plus years so the
opportunity to develop the site is very
positive with the area
in my opinion the objections are far
outweighed by the benefits of quality
housing and new employment opportunities
and the associated trade from these
employees which will benefit the town of
westgate
thank you thank you
i believe it is ian if i'm
that's correct thank you ian if you
would present your report please
thank you chair and good afternoon
members um
hopefully you'll be able to see my
screen now now
um so the application is
uh just confirm it's a recommendation
for uh defer and delegate for approval
um and it's for the sampitas presbytery
site
uh that is on 117 canterbury road
so the proposal is to demolish the
buildings on site
and to erect a four-story
part three-story building with ground
floor commercial offices
and 14 flats spread over the three
upper floors so the principal issues
that
members are considering is the principle
of development
the impact on the conservation area as
well as the impact and
on the setting of the adjacent listed
building
the impact on neighbours uh the impact
on trees
on the site uh highway safety as well as
other planning matters such as
archaeology
ecology and so on
so light is in the center of the image
here so this is an aerial view looking
towards the
south so you can see the existing
building
um then to you to the left of the site
as you looked at it from uh the main
canterbury road
you have 115 to the right hand side you
have
the building known as summerlands which
is 119 canterbury road which is a grade
2 listed building
then at the rear you have countess
mountband court
uh which is uh retirement housing um and
then you can see
behind uh the sort of south part of
uh west gate and you've got sun
augustine's
and the relatively recent housing
development around the back of that
to to the west of this site
to show you a bit more detail so turning
around and now looking north
you can see the relationship between the
main property with the the the pitched
roof
and uh the trees at the front of the
site so you can see that the site is
uh set within the middle of the plot and
you can see some of the landscaping
surrounding and within the site
and also you can see minster road here
which is obviously to the east of the
site of which this site does have a
frontage onto
so this would be from across the road on
the canterbury road towards the site so
you can see the trees
at the front there uh obscuring the view
of the
the church uh in this image so these
trees at the front
are uh subject of a tree preservation
order
um from 1956.
uh then this is a view looking towards
115 canterbury road which is a
residential property that is
on the corner of minster road and
canterbury road
then this is just a further back view
showing the
the trees that are on site at the moment
which obviously have a a very
significant contribution to this part of
the conservation area and the character
of the area
and are all uh protected
uh then looking towards the relationship
with um
the property uh summerlands next door um
you can just see the glimpses of
summerlands behind
the the trees at the front
and here's another view in just showing
summerlands and then i'm going to show
you a view which is actually from
from google street view in so to see a
little bit more of what that building
looks like
um we talked about this last time the
previous application came before members
this site is subject to enforcement
action there are outstanding enforcement
notices
on on this property um and um
and further movement in terms of uh
prosecutions are moving forward as soon
as the courts reopen
uh on those notices not being complied
with them just to give members an update
on that but that is a great two list of
buildings so it's very important that
uh the considerations are given to how
the development adjacent could impact on
the setting of
of this building so then this is
sort of on the edge of the boundary
between those two sites looking through
towards
the church and you can see the protected
trees again in the foreground of the
image
now sort of turning to the right from
this image um
looking down into the site uh adjacent
to summerlands
um so this is actually within the red
line but is actually looking down the
length
uh with the church on the left of the
image
here and uh summerland's on the right
hand side
and this is actually the route that goes
down to the countess mountbatten
uh core properties at the rear so there
is a right of access
over part of the land that's within the
red line of this site and this access is
not
changed by the proposal uh just to just
clarify that in terms of making sure
that there's still a route
down into that site
then into the site um this is the
building in
question and just to pick up um another
question that may come up
in advance of that um there is an
outstanding enforcement
um case with regards to the current use
of this building
um it's being used at the moment for uh
furniture storage as you can
quite clearly evidenced by this image um
as well as uh
for retail use on that ground floor um
we have um required either application
is submitted
or the use ceases uh through the
enforcement case
um but this is obviously primarily an
image just to show you the building
itself
in terms of left from that and within
the parking area at the moment
in the in the site that we're looking at
you can see the side elevation
of 115 canterbury road um so this is
also slightly unique in terms of its
access arrangements because it's
accessed via
the the existing access into
117 so you can see where the red
car is that's actually the access point
into
the property so it's not accessed 115
from canterbury road
or from minster road but also it's worth
drawing to members attention
uh the openness of the front and side
gardens
at this point of um of the site
and then turning to the right from this
view
you can see um just in the ground here
you can
see the the before the first bricks
which is the single stronger that's on
the side
and you can see number of the trees that
are present on the site so it's got some
low trees
here and then you've got a primary tree
that you can see through the existing
canopy of the protected
tree up here you can see there's a tree
that's set into the site
in this facility here this is one of the
trees that's being retained
um and that is also a tree that that is
is shown as has been covered by the tree
preservation order
uh previously
um so this is now a view looking back
towards
uh 115 so the name property
um which is right hand side of the image
um looking back and you can see on the
left hand side you have the
um the actual presbytery and the
bungalow residential part of the
property uh on the left-hand side so
you've got
uh one of the trees here that's proposed
to be removed
and moving back you have this uh this
leaning tree here so this is just going
back for a few steps from the previous
image so you can still see
on the right hand side 115 and then the
uh
the building to be demolished so we'll
run through the the specifics of the
tree plans when we look at the plans
then turning around and looking towards
uh sorry there you go there's another
image of
those trees in particular in the
bungalow on the left-hand side
so then moving uh towards
looking at the relationship with minster
road particularly
so this is an image taken looking i
suppose towards the south
east of the site in the corner looking
towards
minster road these are our two of the
trees that are identified
on the plans the the tree which is on
the left-hand side which is the
the larger of the trees in this group is
to be retained
with the other tree on the right-hand
side proposed for
removal then moving to
turn to the right from the image you're
looking at and looking at the rear
boundary of the site
uh we have the countess mount baton
court is
to the rear uh here
you can see the rear of the church on
the right hand side of this
image and then you have the trees that
form the back boundary and the screening
between
uh the church site and uh the
residential retirement flats
at the rear so these two trees here
are proposed to be retained and then
moving forward
sort of into this image you can then see
these two trees
so both of these trees are are protected
trees they were protected by virtue of a
tree preservation
order in 2009 when an assessment was
made on the trees
on this site and these trees were
considered to be worthy of
retention and preservation at that point
so um as outlined one of the the key
issues is the principle of development
this application is reported
to members as a departure from um the
local plan policy
cm02 because it represents the loss of
the existing community facility um it
has however been outlined by the
the public speaking um that there is a
previous application that was approved
by
members in 2018 which looked at
converting the existing building and
losing the community facility on the
basis of the benefits
from the economic development that was a
result from the commercial office
used at the same time a determination
was made that that would also
not constitute a an issue with regards
to the vitality
and vibrancy of the district center at
westgate and indeed the other town
centres because
it would propose to have an office use
outside of those centres
without providing a sequential
assessment so in terms of considering
this application
applying uh the very significant
material planning consideration which is
members previous decision
on the weighing up of these matters it's
considered that the economic benefits
of the commercial offices and now the
additional 14
residential units outweigh the loss of
the community facility
and the potential impact on the town
center
so looking through the elevations of the
existing building
um the rep or identifies
um that the loss of the existing
building the conservation area is also a
key consideration to be taken into
account
the building itself is unique in its in
its context
as as already mentioned it's it's not a
historic building particularly in terms
of age
but it does reflect quite a few of the
significant characteristics that are
found with development in the
conservation area
because in terms of the development it
is notably set back
from the frontage it has quite a lot of
space around it
in terms of its relationship with other
buildings and it's also quite large in
terms of its scale
so it is considered that this building
does have a positive contribution
to the conservation area however it
isn't considered that this building
is a non-designated heritage asset
by virtue of its um its form as well as
uh the age of the building
and it's not considered that it
contributes significantly to those
particular features of the westgate
conservation area and its historic
development
however because it does have a positive
contribution to the conservation area
it is then important to consider whether
or not the new development
would preserve that positive
contribution and therefore it
it sets a high bar in terms of the
design of the development
um as well as the impact and considering
the impact on the setting of the listed
building
next door
so in terms of the considerations of the
proposed development so
what has been proposed is to retain a
lot of the features
of the layout of the site as it
currently is
trying to maintain the sense of space
from the frontage of the development
so it's set back um as well also having
space either side of it akin to the the
scale of the development that was
previously on the site
um one thing to point out to members
when we move towards looking at the
elevations
is to draw members attention to the fact
the actual footprint of the development
because you can see
that you've got a frontage section of
the building here
which is step back at different points
with a central
uh gable feature which we'll look at
however the two wings of the development
are set back from the main frontage by
10 meters
so there is quite a significant
articulation in the built form that's
being proposed
as well as that it's important to note
that whilst the building is four story
in the center of the building
it's three stories either side and also
single story at the rear
so you have uh this black line noting
the extent to which the building is
four stories in height
so looking at the elevation of the
building um
as mentioned within the applicant's
statement this application has been in
for um
over a year now because we've been
negotiating over the design
um and making various uh requests for
changes to the scheme
and so this is the the final set of
elevations that we're considering today
um so you can see that the the design
approach has been to adopt
more of a traditional approach to uh the
the built form
uh when looking at the building adjacent
with both summerlands and also 115
particularly looking at the fenestration
pattern with the pitch drews
but also the symmetry that's found
within the development
and we do consider that the form of
development that's been proposed
respects the significance of that area
in terms of
those particular points which do
contribute towards the conservation area
in terms of the site at the moment
so looking at a bit more detail at the
proposal
so here are the wings of the development
which as mentioned is set back by 10
meters so
if members can can think about reading
this as a 3d image rather than the flat
2d image that's that's in front of them
so you have the central core which is
trying to take the characteristics of
the existing building which is obviously
sort of forms of central emphasis within
the site
and then looking through at the rear
elevation you can see on the ground
floor
this single story section of the
building
and then that's also shown on the side
elevation so this is the west elevation
looking towards
summerlands and then this is the
east elevation looking towards minster
road
um in terms of a particular point in
with regards to the impact on
neighboring properties
um one of the concerns that was raised
is the potential for overlooking from
upper floor windows with regards to the
rear garden area of 115 canterbury road
and the windows at the front of the
building here
on first and second floor level
are to be obscure glazed and fixed shut
and when we look at the
floor plans you'll see which windows
they serve
so this is just a view to show the
relationship between the the parking
and the existing building so overall the
scale of development with regards to
the setback is considered to um respect
the character of the conservation area
um it's also noted and important to look
at the
the fact of the relationship between the
the listed building next door
um it is considered that the development
would not
compete with the listed building next
door due to the degree of
separation uh that's proposed um as part
of this
um the amendments the the wings have
been set down from the originally
proposed
scale of the building um and just to
show you what that looked like
previously
it was previously proposed when we
submitted a slightly more modern design
like this
which obviously then was changed to try
and reflect more the historic character
but also setting it down in terms of the
relationship
with the listed building next door
and so we do feel that the harm to the
list of building or the setting listed
building which
will inherently come from the
increase in scale of a building on the
site in comparison to what's there at
the moment
has been minimized by the virtue of the
design
and just taking a bit more of a detailed
look at that design because
as as members will will often be
pointing out um
that it's all it's all important with
regards to the actual standard the
materials
that this building is to be constructed
in so we have actually got up front
the details of the materials in terms of
the particular color
so you can see here about the actual
particular specifics of the brickwork as
well as the brick banding
and the colors of the bricks to be
proposed there in terms of the
front and central core of the building
the ground floor of that
is to be is to be slightly differently
detailed in terms of the brickwork
that's being used
but also in terms of how the return
elevations are connected to
the front facade in terms of the
articulation of the different courses of
brickwork
so we do consider that on the base of
the information that's been provided
which would be
conditioned the materials in within the
conservation area
would um you know would reflect the the
vernacular materials that are found
in the area
in terms of the consideration of
neighboring properties i mentioned about
the
windows that are on the return elevation
here being obscure glaze
so that's to avoid impact on the private
immunity space
of 115 countries here and also
here in terms of the relationship with
the countess mountbatten court
uh this is something that was looked at
in quite a lot of detail and is
contained within the officer report
um we're looking at a uh between a uh
it's an 18 meter distance to the rear
boundary
from the four-story elements of the
building
here to the rear boundary and then
there's subsequently
a nine meter distance the other side of
the boundary
uh to the actual uh windows themselves
um so that distance is considered
sufficient to avoid a significant impact
there is also protected trees in the
vicinity of this site as well as the
trees that are to be retained and
therefore conditioned for retention
within the application as well and that
relationship therefore is considered to
be acceptable without resulting in
a significant harm to the neighboring
property
um just to go through the floor plans um
this is the ground floor plan showing
the office development
um that's proposed and then
moving up through the floors we have the
the first floor plan
um and then the second floor plan which
looks very similar but then the
the third floor plan is obviously
showing the central core of the building
which is the four-story element
so just going down to the first and
second floor you can
see that the side windows that i was
referring to to be obscured glaze
are in this area so they are secondary
windows to the kitchen with a primary
window
at the front all of the flats that are
proposed meet the nationally described
space standards that are required
through local plant policy qd04
and then there's the roof plan so this
shows the extent of the development on
the site in red at the moment
in comparison with the extended
development so as mentioned there is an
increase in the built form of the site
on the site um but it does reflect the
the
you know the location of where the
development is at the moment
so just to pick up the the concerns that
have been raised about trees
so this is a plan showing the the
protected trees
um indicated via the tree preservation
orders on the site so outlines that
the trees at the front that are
protected uh the tp has been extended at
this point
to include uh the tpo that i referenced
when we look at the images from the
front that are that are here
and then in 2009 um an assessment was
was done which has then uh protected the
these two
trees here uh on the site the site is in
a conservation area so the other trees
are um are protected by virtue of being
in a conservation area
um which normally would mean that
through a section two on one application
or notification
sorry um then um the works could occur
to the trees
but the applicant has to put a
notification into us
uh for before that uh so that we would
make a determination as to whether or
not we would tpo trees
or raise no objections which are the
only options that we have on those
but obviously this is proposed through
the planning application and planning
application
supersedes uh tpo legislation so
it's for consideration uh today
so this is the plan that's been
submitted with the application which
shows the extent of the trees
on the site at the moment um obviously
some of the comments that have come in
relate to the loss of the trees in the
site
the rationale that's been put forward is
um the
particular need to get the amount of car
parking that's required for the
redevelopment of the site
whilst also retaining the most prominent
trees um to give you some sort of idea
of the trees on the site there are 33
trees on the sides
and the development proposes to remove
eight of those trees
uh and the 15 tpo's that are protected
are all all proposed will be retained as
part of it
so you can see here that the trees in
the center of the site
have been proposed to be removed to
accommodate from the parking area
with specific provisos made to ensure
that the trees
that provide the the screening between
the two developments
are to be retained and including
protective fencing as shown by the blue
fencing here
that's to be erected as part of
the scheme so this is just to show the
protective fencing
um following the comments that have been
put forward by the agricultural officer
um you know we we have gone back to the
applicant and requested
um that there's a further further work
done in terms of what could be retained
um within the scheme and both you know
balancing up the
uh requirement for car parking on the
site uh with regards to
uh the immunity that's offered by the
trees what been proposed
is to retain
um one additional tree so it's only
eight removed originally it was nine
that would be removed originally
uh but it has also included additional
planting that's proposed um with the
proposal
um which was which includes um it's ten
trees in total including
uh six silver birch specifically in
this facility over here so directly
adjacent to where
um the minster road is so just going
through the photos to show you
um the the relevance of these particular
trees
um this is a view looking back towards
the site and the backdrop within the
area
and so at the end here you can see the
traffic lights on the right hand side of
the
image as well as 115
at canterbury road so these trees that
are that are present here
are the highway trees so they're
actually set
on the the public highway so they're not
part of this site
um at all then you have this tree here
which is one of the trees for retention
on the site but then the main backdrop
of the trees um which is behind
the neighboring property on minster road
and we're just going to look at it
on this image which is from google to
get a bit of an elevated view
you can see the backdrop of the trees in
particular
so the as mentioned the highest tree
um on the boundary is to be retained
which is this tree here
and it's the central trees that are to
be thinned out
with regards to accommodating the
parking area in particular
and so using um google just to give
members a sort of
an idea of the 3d nature of this site so
this is a
an impression um that's taken from
google
um you can see that you've got the
highways trees in this area here again
this is
um using satellite imagery so it's to be
it's to be taken account
on that basis and then you have um the
two trees to be retained which are the
ones that you know are clearly visible
from the road
you then have trees to be retained in
this area here so this is the ones that
screen both the neighbor from the
countess mountbatten court which is in
the top left part of the image
but then it's the area of trees here
which is to be thinned out you can see
again here's the
here's the bungalow element of the
building to be
um demolished so it's this area here
which is
accommodating the car parking uh within
the trees
at the very top of the image all being
retained to continue the relationship
between
the neighboring property accountants man
bangkok and
this and the proposed scheme so
it you know is it's regrettable in terms
of the loss of the trees
we do think that should be balanced
against the the benefits of the proposal
and also the
provision of new trees as well as the
retention
of um the the vast majority of the
existing trees
on the site um so in terms of
other planning considerations uh parking
there are 47 spaces
proposed that is obviously to
accommodate
for an office development as well as the
14 residential flats
um they are proposing to slightly widen
the vehicular access
um because highways requested that for
for safety purposes
but it can only be widened to about 4.8
meters because of the fact that you've
got protected trees
at the front of the site and obviously
the key is to not damage any of those
protected trees
at the front of the site um this parking
provision
as indicated does include um
particularly disabled bays in regards to
the site but also would include eight
electric vehicle charging points
to serve the development
in terms of the other considerations we
have there's a heads of terms section
in the report which is identifying
contributions from the 14 residential
units
proposed that includes a contribution
towards the strategic
access management monitoring plan as
well as education community learning
youth
services library book stocks social care
and and waste services
there is a safeguarding condition with
regards to archaeology as well as
additional environmental
psychology surveys to come in
predominantly about a precautionary
principle with regards to a potential
for roosting bats
so there are a number of other planning
matters which have been
put forward to be dealt with via
condition but also
through a legal agreement to secure
those particular contributions
so overall it is considered that there
are um substantial
social and economic benefits from the
proposal uh there is
um uh environmental um harm by virtue of
the
loss of the building um in terms of its
contribution to the conservation area
and the ex and the expansion of built
form on the site
in terms of um relationship with
the neighboring property the listed
building however that has been
mitigated substantially by the revised
design
to minimize that harm and therefore it
is considered
taking into account all relevant
planning considerations that the
application should be recommended
for uh defer and delegate to officers
for approval
subject to the receipt of a unilateral
undertaking to secure the contributions
as well as also
these safe conditions thank you chair
thank you very much ian i moved that the
officer's recommendation
is adopted could i have the vice chair
please second
i'll check on that chair thank you
councillor carmen cook
um i'm gonna ask if i may and i know
uh council scott wants to because of his
work has got to move
um and if i may ask you i mean uh if
i've missed this on the report and it
might not be on the report
um it was a church um
in the mind somewhere through our
training over the years and so on
non-planning
because it was a church has this been
de consecrated do you know would that
cause
it may be a difficult one but it's only
something in the mind where
a new build is going up onto a site that
has you know has
had a religious building on for a number
of years
i don't know if you can answer um yeah
and i i believe this was
um it was looked at when we looked at
the previous application
um it is slightly separate from a
material planning consideration but as
as referenced
it hasn't been church for quite a
significant amount of time and i believe
that
the parishioners have been sort of split
up separately into into other facilities
so
it's not something that that weighs in
terms of the determination that members
would be making
today all right thank you for that it's
only purely
you know if we go ahead if it goes ahead
and so on something could
come and bite us um members i've got
councillor scott um if you're still
there
yeah thank you chair yeah many thanks
yeah um
i had a lot to say about this but yeah
i'm gonna have to certainly keep it
very brief but i think it'll be a
blessing for everyone i mean it's echo
sort of um obviously this is within my
ward uh
some of the points raised by uh our two
ward councillors
as well as the west gate town council um
i mean
as always it's always great to have any
sort of um
potential job opportunities especially
back into fannie
it's always welcomed um i mean obviously
planet is
an area that is screaming to have
opportunities
for a job and uh for this particular
applicant to bring that back into
westgate itself will be really great i
mean it has the benefits of
being built on a potential brownville
site
obviously potential job income and um
also
for the town itself potential for
revenue for the businesses
and the town um i mean i do have quite a
few concerns i mean one of the original
concerns was
actually the development of the actual
um
well the original proposed development
of the building which
based on today's sort of presentation
has really sort of
cleared things up mean the
the first one was very much not in any
way
in keeping with the area it looked like
a bit of a
a holiday home you would expect to get
in spain and certainly didn't fit within
sort of the aspects of westgate at that
particular time
so the the newer sort of development
does
certainly fit ish into the actual
area i mean i'm still a bit concerned
about the the actual overall height
but one of the key things i was mainly
concerned was the traffic concerns which
i'm a bit surprised to being sort of
approved by kcc with uh the access
really um
very close to obviously across the way
um it's a 40 mile per hour speed road um
obviously being so close to the traffic
lights
a lot of cars have been seen and known
to sort of speed up to hit those
particular
light switchings from a yellow to red um
and for this to be with the only access
in and out especially around these sort
of rat race runs between nine o'clock
five o'clock when
businesses do tend to sort of finish and
pack up just a bit of concern really
sort of potential
accidents to happen the tightness of it
overall
um and also the fact that it's very
close to
a main bus stop as well so i mean that
that road in itself will get
extremely busy and obviously
i know we are looking at just the
principal application but
as a west gate will undoubtedly get
bigger um
those roads will get certainly busier so
that was one thing i really wanted to
sort of
address and hopefully and the officer
can come back sway those concerns
because at the moment
that is a very very dense place to have
a lot of movement
around um i mean it's answered a few
others
in relation to the app with character i
i know and noted a lot of the objections
from
residents that it has been undesirable
um
obviously i know we can we could sort of
sometimes short it up to not in my
backyard principles
and i know we do need sort of um
development here
so i'm very conflicted overall but yeah
that was my key aspect really just
that particular issue in the first
instance
and the only other one to address was
that the trees uh which i think are in
pretty much
covered very well the only ones that
been highlighted here where i've been
given so the tree offices report is t18
t19 t20 t21 and t22 which i believe was
on that
proposed car parking area yeah
the other says here with um sort of a
particular
car of all planning and strategic plan
i mean those trees these could
actually be retained so i'm wondering if
that has actually been
um sort of investigated a bit more and
yeah
and can you come back on that yes
absolutely thank you chair um the in
terms of picking up the point about
um the the highways uh concerns
um i you know i i certainly know what
what counselor scott is saying here and
and
it is something that we you know we were
looking at quite in quite a bit of
detail you'll see in the report that
there is an initial comment from kcc and
then a subsequent comment
um because whilst there is an existing
access there and that does
weigh sort of heavily in favor of
redevelopment with site because
obviously highways have to take account
of the fact that well
theoretically this building could be
used uh for
a you know use class in d1 uh which
could be used for obviously a church
because
other uses without needing planning
permission which would lead to movements
in and out of that existing access
um but also obviously taking account of
the the particular safety concerns in
the relationship with the traffic lights
um in this instance kcc obviously who
look at
crash data when making their
recommendations
have considered that it's acceptable and
and i think in terms of the particular
relationship with the traffic lights
um i take the point in terms of cars
potentially speeding up to hit those
traffic lights
um obviously um because of the way that
traffic lights are timed
if a car has turned into this uh into
this road and then is turning into the
access
um then obviously they the expectation
would be that they've moved
out of the two carriageways um
by the time the next lot of traffic
lights are potentially
on and so they're potentially at the the
end of that stage
and it is something that highway's
looked at specifically
um to ensure that um you know it's it's
suitable and safe um to pick up the
point with regards to trees
um i just quickly will present my screen
again to members
just to talk about this particular point
because it is something that obviously
we're very mindful of and
you know um reading out obviously the
the agricultural officer of tdc's
comment
um specifically um
what what's being looked and you'll be
able to see it in this area here
are the the the dotted lines
which are present which are on the
parking area now of those trees that
that were cited so t sort of 18 to
22. t19 is a category u tree and it's
got significant
extensive decay within it and so that
wouldn't
wouldn't be suitable to be retained
anyway with regards to the other trees
we have looked at the potential that was
put forward by the agricultural officer
about
how it could be be planned around but
fundamentally you'll see by the way that
this site is
is is set up as well as the location of
the trees being retained as well as the
side boundary
of the neighboring property to provide
the amount of car parking that's needed
to support the office use as well as the
14 residential units
does require parking provision in this
vicinity
and due to the the relationship with uh
the proposed building
um these trees that are sort of in the
central part of the driveway
um aren't aren't considered sort of able
to be retained
even with the sort of creative solutions
that are being
proposed um obviously the trees on the
edge of this area including this tree
here
is being protected because it overhangs
this area
and this is where there's the particular
um use of
um i think it's geocell is what it's
called uh where you have
effectively almost like mesh above the
the parking area
so you don't compact the soil and you
don't actually have to tarmac it
um but it's not considered that that's
going to work with obviously the
presence of
a trunk of the tree directly in that
driveway
which as you can see is is limited in
terms of where it can be planned
into the development so that has been
looked at that particular suggestion
and therefore it is just it's a weighing
up process for members
in terms of considering whether or not
you know the the you know the
demonstrable benefits that this provides
as well as the retention of the trees
that are on the actual again the main
frontage of minster road
as well as the relationship between the
rear the rears of the property so see
that's where the other
the parking could go but obviously it's
been decided that it's the trees in the
central part of the site
um that obviously don't have as much
visual immunity value in the
conservation areas the others
are the ones unfortunately that would be
proposed to be removed
thank you chair thank you ian
councillor bayford
thank you chair um i'm sorry to some
degree my my
comments have been sort of preempted but
in general i'm in favor of
this application in v in in design
um in with the opportunities for
employment and the emotional housing
but i'm afraid i'm coming back to the
trees um
it seems to me that the removal of these
eight trees
is something which is um desirable
and convenient to development rather
than essential
i just i mean i think in some degree
answer this question but i just wondered
whether with careful
tree management uh
their removable or at least removal of
the healthy ones
could be avoided thank you
thank you did you want to come back ian
although i think you have
sort of has yes i don't think you really
have anything yeah sorry
i probably probably cover this in my um
in my yeah my original comment
i don't think so thank you thank you
thank you uh councillor harp
thank you chair um i've got a few
comments on this because i drive past
this place a lot
um and i know how dangerous that road is
and i don't think that
um having 65 people come to work and
driving in and out
a day um twice a day is probably the
best place that close to the roundabout
up to the traffic lights um i mean this
was used as a church most of people went
to the church for a funeral then nobody
was buried there
um but they went there for a funeral or
they went there on a sunday when the
roads were quieter
more on nine to five during the week and
a lot of these are going to be transient
people because
by by admission it's going to be miles
and bars headquarters so there's going
to be a lot of people driving there
so if they're expecting 65 people to
work there
let's assume 60 of them are going to
drive because they're coming out of town
um
you haven't got enough spaces for them
let alone for the 14
um flat that you've already got um my
other comment
is and i'm i'm really not for this i
think it's over developed myself
but i mean if you also look at uh
the two trees that you were going to
take out you're going to take one of
them out
which means that possibly i think that
was the 2019
agreement uh the tpo that went on if
you're going to take the right-hand one
out unless it's a misleading
photograph that could then over balance
or out balance the
left hand tree and also then cause
damage to the roots are you going to
grind that stump out because you need
access if you're going to drive grind
that stump out are you then going to
damage the ongoing roots for the tree
that's been left
and i think that could be a visual
mistake by me
hands up um are you going to put in
permeable
uh hardscaping for the trees that are
remaining so they actually still get
water rather than just
hardscaping um i just don't think this
is
the right development for this area i
think it's too overdone
i mean there's not even a side access to
to go into minster road where you could
actually alleviate
people coming out of that or going into
the
uh actual area that is going to be used
and i think
you know you've got you can't have
people turning right out of that place
because
it's so on top of the traffic lights you
can't have a right turn out of there so
everybody's going to have to go
left and then you're going to have um
delays further down and turning around
as you do
that people go into the other estate
behind the ursulite
and that causes enough problems as it is
with people coming up on the backs of
people very fast so i don't think for
the amount of traffic that this is going
to be used
is an ideal situation and if you could
come back on that mr livingston i'd be
very grateful thank you
yeah uh yes thank you chair um
so to come back on the the highways
point um obviously
the previous application has approved
the conversion of the existing building
for
offices in fact for the same broadly the
same amount of office floor supposed to
see
propose so that is an extent permission
therefore forms a material consideration
in terms of this new proposal so
over and above what's already got
consent are the 14 units
so that's the element of things that
obviously highways
have have particularly looked at as well
as obviously comparing to the church and
i take your point
um counselor heart obviously in terms of
use of the church
um you would you know obviously pretty
obvious that it's going to be busier on
sunday
but at the same time obviously you know
churches are used for other events
throughout the week but highways have
obviously looked at it
um we would only object to something on
highways grounds when we have
sort of strategic and evidential support
by highways
that there is a specific harm that would
be created
um in this instance um in terms of
suggestions
as to connecting um the the minster road
sort of part of the site with regards to
an access there um you're right there is
no proposed access
at that point um and there certainly
isn't proposed obviously for any vehicle
access because
these days highways wouldn't allow a new
access to be created
so close to the traffic lights um so it
would only have to be only be a
pedestrian access but that isn't what's
being proposed
in this instance um to come back with
regards to
um the the points about the uh protected
trees and those to be removed so
we have had submitted um an additional
um
tree uh sort of plan uh which is the
most recent
um statement that's been put through um
he'd also
um condition 22 on the proposed approval
includes the requirement for a
precautionary method statement
that is particularly to do with
minimizing the impact on roosting bats
but it does also extend to actually how
they're going to do it
as well as how they're going to protect
the existing trees which is covered by
condition 25
um so inevitably because of the
the removal of of the trees on this site
um we are going to have to be very hot
on making sure that when that's carried
out
it's carried out in accordance with
council officers you know uh
on site to us to ensure that the trees
that are to be protected
are present um you know you have a
condition which is requiring any
excavations within the existing spread
of the trees must be done
so manually with with handheld tools so
there is the ability to get further
information in before they do it
and as well as that obviously to make
sure they accord with the requirements
of
of the method statement as well thank
you chair
uh thank you ian uh councillor ghana
thank you thank you very much um yeah i
mean i have a number of um
different concerns about this
application um the first
one that's been mentioned by councillors
bayford and hart
um to do with the trees and i think the
west gate on
sea town council representation
put it better than any of us could put
um i don't
it's such a shame to see so many trees
being lost
especially um in in the current
current climate of a climate emergency
for the sake of a few extra car parking
spaces
and um well i possibly wouldn't
um because of a number of other issues i
have with this
i wouldn't necessarily support it anyway
but it really is
a shame that there are bore cultural
officers
and recommendations aren't listened to
more on this
on this application um
other concerns i have um
i i'll go through a couple of them i
know in the report
tdc housing because it sort of raised
that it raised a red light to me when
when i noted 14 flats being um
being built here rather than 15 which of
course would have
required affordable housing to be
included i noticed that tdc housing
said that supportive comments had been
provided on the original application
which included 30 affordable housing
prior to amendments when i'm reading
that as
the developer has as they've increased
the size of this development i've
actually reduced
the um the number of accommodations
meaning that we're losing a affordable
housing
um i also know that the conservation
officer has
stated that um that the this development
is
larger than than was originally planned
and does have some concerns
um about the whole scheme
um and i will also note that there are
well it's nice to see conditions um
around the production
protection of bats and nesting birds
unfortunately what bats and nesting
birds there are
there are that use this site are going
to be massively disturbed
um during this development and um
it i i think that needs to be taken into
consideration
when this is done because as many back
boxes as you put up
there um there's not going to be as many
about as there are at the moment after
this is completed
and one other concern i had which has
been mentioned around
kcc highways um not raising that many
issues
i drove up there this morning and i'm
very surprised
that um that they don't have any issues
and i don't i don't quite understand
that myself but um obviously they're
they're the experts but i'll leave it at
that thank you
thank you cal scholar um yeah and you
wish to come back on that
uh thank you chad just to come back on
the affordable housing point so
originally it was proposed
um to provide um i'm actually must admit
i don't have the the specific number but
i believe it was
it was 15 or over units within the
scheme
but actually as part of amendments that
have been received the number of units
uh went below the the 14 to 14 units
which is why
originally when proposed included
affordable housing
but then it was reduced um to to go
underneath the threshold that this
application is considered under so
um it's it is yeah it's a again it's a
regrettable
requirement from the change in design
which was fundamentally to reduce the
scale of the development to accord uh
you know fit in more with the
conservation area and
and the listed building thank you chair
thank you and uh council auburn hadn't
forgotten you cancer alban
you wish
he's looking up into the sky cancer
my microphone wouldn't come on
uh yeah i i had a question first i i
just wanted to know
um the height of the listed building
next next door is this
is the new development at the same
height or is it lower or is it higher
if if ian could answer that first please
cheer
yeah i think it's an hour isn't it
uh yeah so what i'll just quickly do
sorry i've
i'll just i'll just present my screen to
show you the street scene
so
hopefully that will in a second
come up
um so you can see that the
eaves height of i don't know whether can
you hopefully you can see the screen now
no no the eaves the eave side of the
building
is is higher um the the ridge height of
the listed building obviously
modulates quite significantly because of
the the chimneys that you've got on
there
um so the ridge height of the main body
of the roof
on this property is taller
than the main body of the listed
building here
which is one of the reasons why the
overall height of the building was
i mean it was originally it was higher
and wider than this which is why it's
been amended to try and give the
separation distance between it so whilst
it's seeing the same context
um in terms of when you are actually on
the ground
level that you wouldn't perceive that
change in height
because of the nature of the the spacing
between them
but also the heights of the buildings so
we have had a look at this the issue of
height
particularly regards the listed building
obviously the building that's on the
site is not as tall as the proposed
building
that's proposed nor is it as wide but
obviously we
we feel that the the site itself and the
character of the conservation area does
support a
a larger building and could support it
without having a
significantly harmful effect on on the
particular designated heritage assets
okay new chair yes carry on
uh councilwoman yeah i i i
support both councillor baker councillor
heart and councillor scott in there
in their views um i'm i
i too have real concerns in relation to
the removal of
the the trees as i see as unnecessary
um one i suppose the one
uh re regret that i have because i'm i'm
gonna uh
i'm gonna vote against this application
it is is
the the job issues you know where we'd
be gonna
um it was gonna create a num a number of
jobs but
i do believe this development is too
bulky for the site
and uh and and i'm concerned about the
lost the loss of the tree so
on on that basis that i will be voting
against
thank you chair thank you councillor
alban uh cancer coleman cook
thank you chair um yeah i've got a
couple of points the
we um gave permission in 2018
um for this to become offices
and create lots of local jobs
and that didn't happen then the next
thing
the applicants put in for um
some housing and office
but it was a bit over the top so they
cut it down to 14
so it just seems to me that again
they they got permission to do something
then they backpedaled then they put in
something else and realized
uh what was going to happen so
backpedaled again
down to uh 14. um
personally and the fact of course that
there's a nice little furniture shop by
the way on that side a minute
um if you need any secondhand furniture
um personally i am totally against it
so we'll be voting against this
application thank you chair
thank you council common cook council
heart you wish to come back
david yeah yeah yeah yes please share
thank you sorry about that
um just a quick question um to resolve
some of the issues regarding this
couldn't they just have an underground
car parking
um okay so go on in off you go
thank you um i i would suggest that um
the the potential to undermine the
protected trees on the site
as well as the majority of the trees and
as well as the potential
uh well not not that it's a particular
consideration of mine
or as the local planning authority but
i'd imagine the costs would be quite
prohibitive
to providing that sort of arrangement
with regards to
to this development but i think it would
be more the concern from my side of
things about
um the potential to undermine um the
you know the existing facilities that
sorry the existing trees that are there
uh thank you ian um i do note uh
thank you matthew i know you i thought
you disappeared already but
um i can't see anybody else i'm
sorry yes there is got two two other
speakers um
councillor curry thank you chair
um i'd just like to add i agree with um
many of the members um
points i do feel particular issues have
not been satisfactorily addressed by the
developer
and i will be voting against this
application thank you
thank you councillor whitehead
thank you very much um i'd like to echo
concerns
um both in relation to the provision of
parking spaces
and the retention of very mature and
significant trees
um so yes i would like to echo concerns
expressed by i think several members now
thank you
thank you um this time i can't see any
other speakers so
i'm going to put this to you um as
always
i have to recommend uh the motion
of the officers which is to approve
and def deferral um
and i go through your names again please
uh yes no or i'm staying i think we're
getting used to this
uh castle coleman cup no
sure council robin against
it comes to paper against council curry
against councillor ghana
again councillor heart
against you councillor zesky
against cancer scott
if you're still there against the church
thank you
uh cancer right against
councillor whitehead against
and i'm gonna abstain on this one um on
this occasion uh
the motion is lost
in over to you
thank you thank you um so um obviously
that's a
pretty clear indication um of the
concerns that
the members have um what um
i think from sort of going through the
particular concerns whilst there have
been
individual concerns about the the scale
of the development
um the particular points that have been
raised
uh relate to uh the loss of the trees on
site
um a particular issue to do with highway
safety
as i've mentioned the highway safety
issue is something that
is picked up through the kcc comments
and
i would raise concerns about refusing an
application on
what is you know legitimate but it's
more anecdotal evidence of concerns
about
highways in comparison to the assessment
that's been done
um however obviously the trees are
clearly the key
issue with regards to this site as i've
mentioned we have
pursued an attempt to pursue a change to
the layout to try and retain as many of
those trees as possible
however i would suggest given that there
are
benefits to this proposed scheme that
one suggestion that i would put forward
to members if if a member was so minded
to move
a motion um would be
that the application is is deferred back
to officers
uh to pursue a reduction
in parking if agreement with highways
can be reached
for that to to try and retain
as many of the mature trees as possible
and then report that back to members at
a future committee meeting
either with a proposed resolution
which shows new plans a new arrangement
with regards to
um you know to keeping those trees on
site
or if no resolution can be reached
uh potential grounds for refusal of the
application
so that is what i would recommend
members do given
uh the concerns that have been raised i
don't know whether any members
rather than move uh some particular
comment on that
um or any queries about what we've
already discussed
uh members uh i think obviously and
yeah answered that very well now is
there any member wishes to sort of
comment
uh please check that out
yes please check my only my only concern
in i approve of what you're
trying to get at and what you're trying
to do my only concern is that
if you reduce an already not sufficient
number of car parking spaces
for that site you're going to push cars
onto the main roads
and the side roads which are just going
to cause
you know if you've got cars parked on
the main canterbury road you've got two
lanes of traffic coming out there's no
red lines there so people can park
we have this is right by the earth line
um you've got
cars accelerating off you've got cars
parked everybody's going to try and get
into the other right-hand lane
it's going to cause absolute chaos and i
don't think you can reduce the number of
car parking spaces
for that site because all you're going
to do is push traffic onto the roads
and the roads won't take it and that's
my main issue with this
it's not the fact that i understand some
trees and to be honest with the number
of trees coming
it's not a major issue for me and i'm a
tree man you know that as much as
anybody
else um and i i i do understand that and
i think someone've got to come down
but i think the problem with with what
you're trying to say is is pushing the
cars onto the side roads
and i don't approve of that at all i
think the road's dangerous enough as it
is
and i think you know you've got to also
look at no right turns
and things like this and you know if you
had cycling access or pedestrian access
through from minster road then maybe
that would help
um but i think it's got to be looked at
as a whole rather than just a
fundamental
what you just said sorry
um thank you council heart if i'm a um
uh i totally like you you mentioned
presume
we shouldn't presume not not at this
stage um
i i do totally understand i know in the
area like you
most of us do it and the traffic along
there and you've mentioned other places
where
you have to get in the second lane
because of parking
um but again it has been mentioned
obviously with the kcc report
there's no problems and as you've heard
we have to take notice of that
um i think at the moment um ian has come
up with
um this is my view and
you are the committee is well could be
acceptable um
totally understand council heart what
you're getting about
the presuming um the thing isn't built
or anything like that
as yet uh so we have to bear that in
mind um
council bayford thank you chair
um i do support in suggestion
um i believe that with
careful planning it may be possible to
retain the number of parking spaces
without the removal of the trees i'm no
expert but i feel it's important enough
it could be done
and i i've a as i said in every other
way i do support this application
no i would be in favor of indigestion
thank you chair thank you
yeah i think it's just to clarify maybe
it's it would
be clearer if um it's not um
maybe my wording was slightly crude that
actually what we would pursue
would be either a reduction or
a rearrangement of the parking
um it's going to very much depend on um
you know actually
you know getting into a room getting on
site potentially and
and negotiating on the detail of this
uh and then taking any sort of
change to the highway arrangement which
may affect numbers to highways
um and so that's why i think it's
something that
you know would require further
discussion we've already done that to an
extent but obviously
the applicant has now heard members
specific concerns
about this particular issue and
therefore it does put more weight
on them looking at these issues and
seeing whether or not there is a
a way to resolve it so i think we could
probably tweak that motion
to reflect maybe you know to avoid the
concerns that
it would have to be a reduction in order
to safeguard
some of the the trees that are that are
here um and that
if if it is a reduction we would
obviously have to get highways
approval of that before we bring it back
to members for a decision
thank you thank you and uh council robin
yeah thank you chair i
i think is this is difficult and and
what i mean by that is that a number of
us have
come up with different views and
different reasons we're all
we all have gone for refusal of this
application but for
but for different but for different kind
of reasons i
i certainly uh think the actual
development is too bulky i don't like
the look of it
i think it's objectionable on the street
scene um
together with the loss of the trees
um i i'm i'm not as uh vociferous as
as councillor heart in relation to the
uh to the highway issues because
of you know they've made it clear
they're quite happy with it and
and such so um
i am i have different difficulty
in uh it going back to officers
uh to to look at it purely on the
grounds of looking to see how we can
associate with the parking in different
ways so um
i'm not happy with that with with that
at all chair thank you
thank you councilwoman cancer right
microphone microphone
so there we go okay um
something i'm quite surprised none of it
no myself as well because i've just
thought of it
um we are presuming that all the
employees will be using
cars now would it be appropriate that we
could
um encourage the miles and bar to use
come up with things like car sharing and
hey ho
the current topic at the moment is
cycling
which would cut down the the employee's
cars
i i think council right that could be a
difficult one
um to tell people uh i totally
understand what you're saying about
cycles but i think we're all aware at
the moment
we have massive issues in fanuc with
people riding bikes
because they're going about 100 miles an
hour um
not quite that but um i don't know
whether i'm
gonna speak to ian or look at ian and
say
you wanted to comment yeah that is
something that
i think all of these things can be
looked at um within
sort of a further discussion with the
applicant to try and resolve the issues
um around this application because as
has been pointed out by
all of the members everything here is
interconnected because
you know it's a combination of the use
generates the parking the parking then
generates the pressure on the trees
so it one one change does affect another
so um what i think in in terms of the
office of recommendation
would be you know would be to defer back
to officers on the proviso that we would
look
at trying to resolve the particular
issues with regards to the trees
and that in the event in in either way
whether there's a resolution there or
not we report the application back to
members
uh we provide what the resolution is if
we've been able to reach one
and that's then something that we would
put forward a recommendation to members
to approve it
but what the report would also do is
look at potential reasons for refusal
along the lines of what has been
discussed
so then it gives a bit more clarity for
members about what the particular issues
are when they're making the
determination um
to get sort of a common consensus you
know as council organs mentioned
obviously we've got a few different
things being mentioned by
different members and so try and get
that collective consensus
um is i think best encapsulated within a
report that comes back that provides
commentary on potential reasons for
refusal
as well in the event obviously that the
resolution is not satisfactory
to two members uh thank you for that ian
i i will take counsellor ghana and then
i'm going to draw a line
i think it's been explained members and
i totally understand what
all members are saying here as well um
one of those difficult ones and we need
to get it right
uh council ghana yeah so i won't i won't
take up a lot of time i i was just i was
going to agree with
councillor alban um because there were a
number of reasons why some of us
rejected it
but i also agree with his what he's just
said that uh to enable us to move on and
i think we should agree
i agree with mr livingto livingstone
suggestion
yeah thank you for that council thank
you
council robin i appreciate i've
suggested what you've put here um
um and uh that's from council auburn
that uh we move on
and would support what again has said
um were you gonna say something again
yes so um for ease
um i think if i read out while i've
scrolled down in front of me
um and uh to move forward with that then
chair if you can then move that motion
and get a seconder um then i think
um for the purposes of the the minutes
um i think it's probably isn't necessary
to do just a
the classic recorded vote and go through
each list of cancers again
go along with that yeah so i'll just
figure in terms of the motion and this
um this may wording may be refined in
the minutes but you'll get the general
sense of it
which is to defer to officers to pursue
um
alternatives to car parking and the
layout
with the agreement of kcc highways to
seek to retain the mature trees to be
removed from the site
and report back to members in a future
planning committee
with a proposed resolution and also
potential reasons for refusal
thank you i will go for that um
so i move what uh mr levinson has
said
i'm not going through names as you heard
there um
do you all agree agree
agreed right i think
thank you very much thank you ian for
the explanation there's
one of them we need we'll need to get it
right it's okay
um i'm going to say it doesn't
need a break down the road for anything
or
no
sorry i have to be in bed by at least 10
o'clock if that's all right
you've got no chance um
i could say we're online we're live
uh anyway that concludes the public
speaking um
for this meeting i will call upon
charlotte if she could
read out the gender item
which there's two as you know two gender
items remaining
one that we're not speaking about um
which is 4b
i've said it but if charlotte wishes to
read that out if anybody wants to
speak about it please say so charlotte
17 harbour street ramsgate
thank you is there any comment on that
no okay so um
a proposal that that is all okay
please yes
second someone your body
did you get that charlotte yes
you get into getting to know the voices
okay
all agreed agreed
thank you agenda item
five uh which is land adjacent to samson
grange
nash road um a council of parents
was going to be with us this afternoon
to speak about this you may have
received an email with her concerns but
um earlier this afternoon she gave her
apologies so i'm going to ask uh the
planning officer to
report please
uh thank you chair i will just um
present
my screen
um so members would have seen this is an
agenda item
um because it relates to sort of a
couple of
unique circumstances um so we have um an
outline planning application
uh that was resolved for approval by
members in august
2017 and that's outline approval for
for those for 250 houses with highways
infrastructure included
um and access include
being reported uh back to members
following
um consideration of the viability
of the development and is also reported
back because of the
length of time that it's been since
members originally resolved to grant the
application therefore it's important to
consider whether or not
any of the material planning
considerations have changed
um so i'm going to give a brief
introduction to the
uh outline application itself um i will
keep it brief
um so that members if they have any
particular questions they can come back
on it
but it's important to note obviously
that this has been resolved to be
granted in terms of
the development itself um in in 2017 by
members so
this is the site uh in question so this
is
a allocated housing site in the new
local plan under policy h03
you have nash road along the
the top end of the site you have some
gregory's primary school
adjacent to the site then you also have
manston road here which joins up then
with shot and dane road
at this point here and then you have the
allotment site the crematorium as well
as the cemetery
to the south of the site so this is just
an aerial image
and again you can see those particular
features that i've mentioned
and then this is a view looking over
towards uh nash road
so you can see here the allotment site
adjacent to the the
allocated site um and the the cemetery
and the primary school
so the application as mentioned proposed
250 dwellings
one of the key elements of this site is
the fact that it forms
an allocated site on the basis of the
strategic infrastructure which is to
support the
transport strategy and to support um
the infrastructure under policy sp 47
which is to build a road through this
site to connect
manson road and nash road
that involves the construction of a
roundabout
on the fronting mansion road
and then a new realignment of nash road
to bend around and go through this site
with then a new junction put in to link
to the dwellings that front nash road
itself
um that is this
is uh illustrative layout plan
um that was provided with the
application um so
this is a plan to demonstrate how the
site could accommodate the 250 dwellings
that the site has been allocated for
i mean it includes a large amount of
open space in this area
this has a dual purpose it's tough to
accord with the requirements of the
policy about size of open space to be
provided but it's also to provide
um suitable screening to um the
the listed building that's in here um
as well as that you can see just the
relationship between
uh general idea between the neighboring
properties and the site
um however obviously that is a matter
for consideration at reserve matters
and it's important to know that when
agreeing to resolve to grant the
application
in august 2017 members also resolved
that any future reserve
matters application that was submitted
to the council should automatically
be referred to planning committee and so
that is still
proposed to occur
so looking just quickly at those
highways works specifically
um you have this is the roundabout um
that's been
that was designed to be put forward and
there are particular conditions that are
outlined in the report in annex
one which looks at the detail
of this infrastructure and design and
allows for
the submission of partial revisions to
this
infrastructure in terms of what it looks
like in accordance with discussions with
kent highways
however it can't deviate from the
specifications and requirements
that this roundabout would provide in
terms of lanes width
and so on this does also provide
[Music]
a a new road that would serve these
properties that currently front
nash road as well as a parking areas to
be provided
one of the particular concerns that was
obtained detailed by members previously
was the impact on residents from this
roundabout
and you'll note by um annex one
there are particular conditions which
relate to the impact on immediacy of
neighbours including the need for
a noise mitigation scheme to be provided
and that actually has to be provided
in advance of the submission of the
reserve matters
so the reserve matters application which
shows the data
has to be has to take account of the
noise scheme because obviously some of
the solutions that are going to be made
to try and avoid
impact on neighboring properties are
going to result in a layout
that must fit in with that scheme so
it's to try and make sure that the
timing of all these different things
uh come in accordance to ensure that one
does follow
the other and this is just showing the
detail of the other end of the site with
regards to the link down to
nash road and then
we have i suppose the primary reason why
um this site
is part a key part of the transport
strategy and as a solution is coffin
house corner
which um i'd like to say needs no
introduction
um but obviously members will be
familiar with this junction but you can
see it's obviously
got five different uh exits as well as
empire terrorists having a little access
off here
as well um so the main thing that this
development would bring forward
in terms of changing this is to close
off
the nash road arm of this junction which
is in accordance with the
transport strategy of kcc which will
obviously reduce the signalized junction
changes by
by one whole arm um which would also
then direct
traffic that wants to go towards
westward up and via
the new roundabout uh to go then through
the local
distributor standard road which would
see a wider road than would normally be
required that goes through the site
which would also be able to accommodate
four buses and that sort of thing
so what would occur here is that this is
closed but it would also
still include access up to empire
terrace
um so it would remove what is a
particularly awkward relationship
with um people coming up um college road
and trying to go into empire terrace
although it's a limited number of
movements because of the number of
dwellings that are on
empire terrace so there's a
also a condition which means that the
road connection has to be provided
before this is closed off
as well for obvious for obvious reasons
and then the last bit of highways works
that the site would bring forward
um is to change the prioritization that
occurs at the junction between manston
road
and schottendame road so um
i'm sure most of most members will be
familiar with the fact that at the
moment
you are waiting a giveaway site a
giveaway junction
on the manston road to join schottendame
road well this would change that
and changes that in line with the
increase in movements that actually
occur going down that's the road as
those movements that would come via the
link to
westwood that this site would would
produce
so that's therefore there's a change in
the prioritization
here as well now all of these highway
works
are linked to a phasing condition
that is proposed which is for no
development should take place
until a highways work phasing plan is
submitted which is condition 21
and this is to ensure that modeling is
done to work out
when the different things come online as
the site develops
to make sure that we're both supporting
the ability for the site to develop and
access via vehicular transport
but also ensuring that there are no
adverse impacts on the network
by not having the relevant
infrastructure in place uh before
um before all the traffic is using it
from both the development and also
the surrounding road network
so that's a a was probably minor fault
brief a brief introduction to that
application
in terms of um the the main reason this
is being reported back to members
is on the grounds of viability so many
people have seen from the commentary in
the report that there was
a um submission of a viability appraisal
to the council
which proposed 30 affordable housing but
on the basis that
all of that housing was shared ownership
with no affordable rent on a viability
grounds
due to a combination of factors but
predominantly due to the
highways costs in addition to what you
would normally expect a site such as
this
to provide um and the reason why um
this this has um you know this
originally this viability came in
um just over two years ago and the
reason why it's been two years later is
because there's been significant amount
of negotiation
around that viability appraisal and
quite a lot of back and forth
of which is is outlined in the report
so one of the principles behind
the council's housing strategy as well
as the local plan
is to try and maximize the amount of
affordable housing that's provided
by sites including allocated sites such
as this one
and the point of report which is 3.5 of
the report for members
outlines about affordable rent and um
in the presentation earlier um fibbing's
outlined about the particular need
for affordable rent and specifically
when it comes to
those on the lowest incomes and those
that are on the housing
the housing register that the council
has so the scenario that's put in front
of members which has been tested
for viability um is one that provides 18
affordable housing on the site but that
split is a 70 30 split being 70 percent
of that
of the 18 is affordable rent properties
which is 32 of the units
whereas the rest are shared ownership to
try and maximize the amount of
affordable rent
and so that is the affordable of the
viability scenario that has been tested
it's been tested um doubly almost
because what we did do is make sure that
we got
uh some consultants via kcc
to go through the costings of the
constructing of the road and the
additional cost that
the roundabout the link road the
off-site works would
would be required to provide um and that
has all been fed into the viability
appraisal which is then subsequently
checked and put forward by officers um
and that is
um therefore put forward to agree
the recommendation to reduce the amount
of affordable housing
on the basis of those very specific
costs to do with
this particular site um
it is considered you know we've talked
about this before members about
with the manchester green development
recently um and and
the issues with viability and um you
know it's very important that we are
maximizing
absolutely every every amount that we
can get in terms of affordable housing
on sites
however it is considered reasonable in
this instance given
um the specific requirements of this
site to provide the strategic highway
improvements
that this is um this is an equitable and
and
reasonable solution to bring forward the
development on this site
um as well as that um the report also
outlines
um additional um considerations with
regards to the new fanatic local plan
which has obviously been adopted
subsequently and this manifests itself
in in
in a couple of brands one is that all
new development is required to accord
with the nationally described space
standards
so there is a condition that's proposed
to be added to those safeguarding
conditions in annex one
that requires all dwellings shown in the
reserve matters applications
to accord with the national space
standards as well as that there is the
requirement under the same policy
uh which is qdo4 that there would be
increased water efficiency from new
housing development
to 110 liters per person per per
day which connects to the building
regulations which then
means that they can get that through
building ranks as well
and as well as that there are some
updates that will need to occur to the
existing planning conditions that
members approved previously
uh with regards to policy references uh
there is a reference to
lifetime homes which are now enshrined
in the new local plan
to um access adaptable and accessible
houses
which are also enshrined in part m of
building rigs so there are a few
conditions that need
updating as well um
in the last point that the report also
identifies is the change that's occurred
to the understanding of the habitat
regulations assessment that's required
for new residential development in the
district
and that required an appropriate
assessment to be carried out in advance
of determination and in advance of
agreeing
the mitigation for the impact on the
special protection area
uh caused by additional recreational
pressure
um that has been agreed by natural
england
and that appropriate assessment has been
um and
has been um therefore put forward um and
it's considered that the heads
and in the report would cover the
mitigation to
avoid the impact on the special
protection area there are also some
changes to the heads of terms because
things have moved on in the last three
years in terms of kcc contributions
and therefore those are changed and
those are those are detailed in the
report
as well and so therefore overall
this application is recommended to defer
and delegate for
approval subject to the the
the ratification agreement of a legal
agreement
curing the contributions and the
affordable housing
amount as outlined in the report with
the conditions in annex
one updated with the addition of the two
conditions
um to reflect the the new local plan
uh thank you thank you ian
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted
could the vice chair please second or
second nature
thank you members
uh i have questions here
from amsterdam
hi chair yeah thank you um here we go
again
cancer album yeah thank you am i on yeah
thank you your request to speak
yes thank you can you hear me all right
thank you okay you weren't moving chair
you're stuck
um that's better um uh
here we go again you know we've got
developers come in
a site agree affordable housing or
whatever it may be
uh then they don't do it for a few years
and then
things change they want this they want
that and they want to reduce the amount
of afford affordable housing i'm sorry
chair i do not agree with this at all
and will not be supporting this thank
you
thank you uh councillor whitehead
thank you chair um
as always affordable housing is
a very complex area um we hear the
phrase
and we think that it simply encompasses
particular forms of social housing but
as evidenced by this
when we have part by part rent
you're looking at very different
scenario to
affordable rentals and
i think unfortunately when it comes to
larger developments
because we rely on larger developments
to fulfill a lot of our infrastructure
needs
because we frankly don't receive
sufficient funding centrally in order to
do it ourselves
um we're quite often
put in extremely difficult situations
when it comes to fulfilling
our requirements to our residents and
our residents
are at the heart of this their housing
needs and their accommodation needs
should always come first so i recognize
that the form of housing that's being
suggested
now fits our population better
affordable rental is
much more appropriate for our area i
would say
but we are almost halving the
contribution
at this point and i don't think that can
be underestimated
i'm unhappy with this to say the least
um and i think if we are to make any
alteration especially
especially one that is this significant
then we need to be looking frankly at
a much higher percentage of affordable
rental because that is what we need
um so if we are to drop
to this very significant level um i
would be expecting that frankly it would
be a 100
affordable so that we can actually
provide the services that we need
to our residents thank you
uh thanks for that councillor whitehead
uh councillor heart
thank you chair um i must agree um with
council auburn
it's exactly the same scenario get the
builders in
work out they all know what they've got
to do from the outset
so three years later they come back
using old figures they turn around into
and say well we get some very clever
accounts and we can't afford to do it so
therefore we're not going to do it
it's got to stop this is going to happen
on every single thing
and we can't just let them get away with
it and i mean at the end of the day they
knew what they were entering into
when they took this on and it's as
simple as that
and we just have to make sure that we
are giving
our residents affordable housing
and this is not achieving it and you
know it
i know they've got to put infrastructure
but they knew that when they took it on
it's not a surprise to them um and i
just think we've got to make sure that
we stick to our guns and say
no you agree 30 and the full cop
associated with that to give to
everybody else and they've got to do it
thank you council heart council ghana
thank you yeah i i am i agree with
what's been said by the previous
speakers
um as he as uh mr livingston mentioned
we've recently
looked the last one we spoke about
mountain green was a
reduction which came in quite quickly
reduction in affordable housing
and it seems we're we we roll over quite
quickly to
to developers and looking at some of the
dates i know
with the committee approved this on
august 2017
it was nine months later that the
developer had their viability
statement ready and submitted asked
for this reduction and i think it's it's
um
it's wrong i think we we should be
sticking to our guns on this
thank you thank you council ghana um
here and you wish to come back
uh thank you chair um yeah just i just
wanted to
to come back um in terms of the
consideration of viability evidence
um the national planning practice
guidance
gives quite a lot of detail about how
local authorities have to consider
the viability concerns um that when
they're put forward
um you know in this instance we are you
know very mindful
of the reduction of affordable housing
and i i
i i disagree
uh that uh this reflects
um uh any sort of uh
position that we would normally take to
uh to
to just allow the reduction in
affordable housing you can see
from the annexes to this report the
extent to which this has been looked
into indeed
turn l uh the report also outlines how
um you know
we we're not we're not we're not green
when it comes to what's hidden in
viability assessments
um you know we've seen the time and time
again
um unfortunate we bring it to members uh
when we are convinced by it
there are lots that don't come to
members um because we've
we've secured the required amount um so
it is um it is something that's
regrettable we wouldn't be putting it in
front of members because
obviously i i absolutely understand the
reaction um
but you know it is put forward on the
basis of this evidence um
and we do think that in this instance
given the nature of this link
and the evidenced costs that are
associated with this link for 250 houses
which is an additional
three uh 3.7 million on top of what you
would normally
you know be sort of putting into your
costs for the internal roads
it's an additional three million this
site has to bear
so it is considered that this is a
solution to both bring forward
housing development um with maximizing
the
the viable amount of affordable rent
that you can provide on this site
um you know with that infrastructure
coming forward as well that's that's why
we've we've put it in front of the
members
thank you chair uh thank you in council
right
thank you mr chairman um i'm wondering i
i agree i grew quite a lot what helen
said
um um i made it known to a lot of people
i i actually do favor shared ownership
rather than
affordable housing because i think it
puts a lot more people onto the housing
ladder
and helps them on a path to owning their
own
home but i'm wondering if is there a
compromise here
um you know 18 that's a big reduction
i would have thought maybe 24
would be a much more realistic figure if
we if we have to
cave in thank you
uh thank you council right councillor
zesky
yeah thank you chair um i actually agree
with
councillor whitehead here uh i think um
it would be nicer to see a greater
um rental uh property
allowance rather than going down shared
ownership
um and make the affordable housing truly
affordable
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
zesky um now i don't have any other
speakers um i
i don't know whether you want to come in
there
um yes um
thank you chair um well i think i think
um
for risk of going to the vote um to to
um
to to get the same result as on the
previous item
um i think i think it'd be
you know i understand what members are
saying and that there are obviously
alternative splits that can be provided
and the issue and concern would be in
terms of
looking for a 100 affordable rent is
that obviously
shared ownership properties have a an
increased amount
of gross development value in comparison
to affordable rent
um in terms of how much they they go for
and how they work in the viability
appraisal so
if you increase the amount of of
affordable rent
um it would lead to a potential
obviously decrease in the overall amount
of affordable housing but clearly
members uh you know collectively
um obviously we've had uh seven sort of
members
speak about this one are of the mind
that the the current reduction
in affordable housing is is not
acceptable um in when looking through
both the report and also the evidence
that's been uh produced
um so um you know i'm
in the in the spirit of of trying to
resolve this matter as as much as we can
uh given that this is a strategic
allocation um
with obviously the the chairman's uh
it's the chairman's discretion whether
it's sort of curb i'd
recommend um potentially that the motion
that's in front of members
um you know potentially would be
withdrawn if the chairman
was so minded um with the um
with the the vice chairs who seconded it
also
if in agreement with drawing um for it
basically to go
back um for the next month for further
negotiations as to alternatives
to try and increase that number of
affordable
units um with the minutes noting uh
members particular concerns about the
reduction
on the basis of the evidence of
viability that's there um
maybe that you decide that it should go
to the vote so that's recorded
uh and then we put forward a motion it's
it's entirely up to you
uh thank you ian um again thank you for
your advice there and
listening to members um again we we've
got a very difficult one here and a
totally
impartial which i have to be uh but i do
understand
what is being said and haven't read the
reports um
but i know it's been put on my shoulders
which i don't mind that's what i'm here
for um
i would ask that this is
withdrawn if members if i can get a
second
for that and it comes back
you sorry oh sorry it would it would
need to be that the
seconder of the motion would have to
agree
to it to be withdrawn yeah yeah um
i'm putting forward that this is
withdrawn if i can have
on a second chair thank you council
coleman cook
um and and
so sorry to sorry to interrupt um but
therefore what i what i would suggest in
terms of emotion
is is very similar in a way to the
motion that was put forward last time
in so much that uh that we we go back we
we negotiate any any further if we can
add to the proportion here
the concerns of members about two things
one
um the potential for the overall
reduction of affordable housing to see
whether or not
irrespective of the evidence the
applicant is willing to increase the
amount of affordable housing provided on
the site
um and and about the proportion of
affordable rent as well
um and if not the application is then
reported back
uh similarly uh for consideration uh of
um you know of potential reasons for
refusal um it will also obviously
include the officer's view which
has is enshrined in this report is that
the application should be approved but
it will cover
all of those things uh thanks for that
ian and members
you've heard mr livingston's comments
there and advice
which i think is fair um
and i've had a second for my proposal
um i won't go through with the list of
names again if you could indicate
whether you would be
happier that to bring it back to the
committee sorry sorry chair it will need
if if it's possible record your vote if
you you know
if you could move the motion i didn't
sorry i didn't hear a second
to the that motion so if you move the
motion that i proposed
cancer common cook seconded excellent
thank you for that story i missed that
okay um if you wish me to go through
um if you're happy members and say
uh a very difficult one once again um
and if this can be resolved um in the
coming weeks
as we've seen this afternoon with the
other application
um i think it make the whole thing make
sense uh
totally understand members and i have
views on this is
obviously as well um i will go through
names
um instead of just a a you know all the
rest of it
if you could agree with the comments
that will be made to bring it back
um if you agree would you please say yes
or no or abstain counselor coleman cook
four council robin against
council baker for
councillor curry for
councillor ghana against
councillor heart uh for what
uh bringing it forward again if that's
right i think you've been getting
confused with what's going on here
no sorry counselor heart to bring it
for the officers to go back look at it
look at the application negotiate and
then bring it back to committee
yeah for that sorry chair hey thank you
uh councillor zesky four
council right for councillor whitehead
we lost sorry uh for
renegotiation thank you and myself
um four um so once again
and thank you for that and again a
difficult one and members
um a difficult one
the motion has been carried
right i think after
whatever we finished
um this afternoon i know it's been a
long
long meeting members and i appreciate
obviously we're all at home or
somewhere um i always say to you
thank you um keep well family
safe and all that we're going through
and
can i just say can i just thank the
officers for putting up with
us tomorrow afternoon
nothing unusual there counts are all but
when you took them
um again i said as well but
um a lot of background work goes on as
we all know
and yeah thank you very much